but your legs
you have a very nice smile i like the
nose ring i like the jewelry
i think you're very pretty wow thank you
you do
however remind me of my ex-roommate who
i am not a fan of
so to get back at them you're going to
use me
i love i love the voice i love
everything about that no matter
the moment hello
i think she was just pity i don't i
don't think that was really her voice i
think it was just
oh you're going to use me to get back in
oh you're cute but
not so cute so to get back at them
you're going to use me
oh that was bad no that was pretty that
wasn't
i was ready i love this
yo yo yo yo
tell me what you're doing here today
today i am ranking people's
attractiveness
where do you fit by society standards i
think most people would say my face is
like
traditionally attractive the rest of me
is questionable i have a wheelchair and
a lot of tattoos so it's a little
different
okay i'm gonna go ahead and bring
everybody in
what's up fayette i'm just imagining
dating a girl in a wheelchair right now
i don't think that would be a problem
what do you mean for me it wouldn't be a
problem
oh yeah for you might not be a problem
it's definitely a problem
no it's some yeah it's going to be
there's effect like yeah there's
difficulties
to it i'm not saying like no it's the
same thing it's exactly the same
there's the imagination hey babe you
trying to go hiking you're just like
look hopefully
well there's all kinds of limitations
that you know hop on
you have to be able to be wit you have
to be able to be witty
willing to do you know sacrifices that's
what a relationship is depends what kind
of sacrifice you want to do hello
how are you doing today i am good how
are you i'm good thank you
you are not my type but
i'm not so tight i mean she got mad
tattoos yeah
you don't you're on you don't like you
don't like mad tattoos not to her degree
like if your whole body's covering them
then no
you're not a fan no but then also these
ladies also
they go for a certain look the reason
why she's not into him is because he's
too clean
um possibly or something else
no nothing all right men i typically
date um
heavier set tattooed gross boys that
look like they smell like top ramen
because we know the type top ramen i am
attracted to
losers and you don't seem to be one you
imagine all her ex is looking like
yeah i'm a loser
i really like your outfit thank you you
have a very nice
nah nah what you like his drip
this man came out wearing his grandma's
pajamas
nah nah bro you like his drip you don't
like pajama pants
bro he came out today looking like i
look
interesting you know when they try
really hard to look interesting yeah
but that [ __ ] just comes off as basic
yeah like [ __ ] we get it you went to
the salvation army we get it
you have a very nice bone structure all
your features like fit
really nicely together yeah you're
attractive
a smile yeah instead of giving a rating
out of attention you just say loser out
of 10.
how much of a loser are you you realize
that anybody who comes down there is
seven
oh wow you're in ten you're a ten loser
you're wow you're ten losers
you realize bro anybody who comes on
that show it gets highly rated by her
is a loser yeah that's crazy so they
don't know that but when they're gonna
watch this video back to be like
damn damn the girl in the wheelchair
said i'm a loser
what you're doing is working i think i'm
going to give you a 10.
oh okay
it's what she's attracted to yeah she's
using the eye to be older but
god damn beauties in the eye of the beer
older what would you
rank me on a scale of one to ten
probably an eight
just trying to find out if she could get
it there he said an eight
you can get your two legs back exactly
for each leg
i just want to hear i hope she asked
what can i do to improve
oh wow if she does i'm tripping your
tattoos are [ __ ] sick that's like
sick the dyed hair is sick
you have like a very like greek goddess
type face like it's sick
but your legs
you hey man i don't even know if these
kind of jokes are appropriate
oh they're not she cute though you know
it is what it is
she's good she's very attractive she she
getting hers she's getting hurt she's
been on this show a couple of times for
other dating stories so yeah she feels
yeah well that's like not necessarily
like the type of person i'm always
looking for
okay does that make sense yeah that was
like the
nicest possible way to say that i'm not
your type
she's great she's amazing street i like
that
yeah like that yeah yeah she yeah yeah
she's used to being let off nicely she's
like
man cut the [ __ ] yeah i know i know
yeah i know
at the end of the day like listen when
someone's in a wheelchair like don't
dance around the fact but also don't
make that the whole thing about you no
you know like right now it's just an
interesting part of the conversation
because i'm not used to seeing stuff
like this but
if i was to meet her i wouldn't be like
how am i gonna act
they see me rolling you know i'm not
gonna you know
i'm not gonna just just start singing a
millionaire yeah
yeah it's a thing but it's not a thing
it's not it's a thing but don't make it
a thing
yeah it's like everyone got they think
that you make you laugh about them for
it and you move on like me it's my
forehead okay we all get it five head
blah blah blah move on with your day
right
preach right sugary it is what it is
you move on from there right is it nice
this is you just having a laugh
all right all right all right we're good
thank you you have a nice day
i'm not into greek goddesses
ah jesus christ you look good i'm sorry
man
you [ __ ]
might not be into greek goddesses but
i'm into nubian queens
huh my egyptian emperances because
egyptians were black
good day [ __ ] and [ __ ] good day sir
today we are in class for class is in
session
boy i have a confession okay she anubian
goddess
girl you the hottest oh yes she is
in the land of god
you know i give you the nod
cause you dark not like chocolate
something more solid
more like the rocks from the moon the
way they reflect
on my boom they're kind of great i'd
like to be on your boom da
hey girl when can i see you sooner
hey
[Laughter]
then i give her the cha-cha go one
and then i just snap on the booty
press play drink a little matcha i'm
thai seeder
you have a very nice smile i like the
nose ring i like the jewelry
i think you're very pretty wow thank you
yeah i don't really care about like i
don't care if she has long legs you know
i don't know that's not your thing when
they have long nails no
it's gross uh yeah no i don't i think
it's gross i don't care yeah when they
got that long and nails but if you at
least know how to handle them like i'm
waiting it only deducts half a point for
me i'm i'm with it i don't do
nothing i'm craig nice to meet you you
look like you take care of yourself
is that not true yeah you gave me a
little shrug i don't like
work out religiously but i try to keep
myself put together
as best as possible your style i think
is not something that i would
personally be drawn to i kind of like um
grungier dirtier looking people i
want to give you like a six
your socks but she said like a fix
she meant four but i knew she was gonna
say sex yeah because
you can't that's how women right now
yeah it's
six seven hot
seat that's why i like the model
people three four
zero no you know what i mean big seven
high
let's go that's it but people being nice
your socks match your shirt that's cool
you look good you look good you're you
know you uh
you're on time yeah that was the nicest
way for you to say that he's not your
type
just saying the [ __ ] you gave the other
dude you're doing the exact same to this
too
hi nice to meet you right when you first
came out i noticed that you
very well put together i like the outfit
it's very modern it's very chic
thank you you also seem very nice i
think a lot of people would see that
you're like very pretty
and maybe think that you're not nice
because typically
people just automatically assume you're
a [ __ ] because you're pretty yeah
pretty much
i'm not a [ __ ] and she says that in a
[ __ ] tone
like from some male fragility maybe but
it's also
women like women look how this guy male
fragility
uh no are you talking about judgment of
like women's character
most of the time it comes from other
ladies they hate that
yeah yeah in terms of cattiness that's
y'all that's your game
this man came in with the uh
hey don't be putting that on us bro
listen listen she came in here looking
like sonya blade okay
straight out of mortal kombat we
appreciate her nobody gonna hate on her
like that be like hey mom you fine
and then she don't respond there's
always a couple of [ __ ] from brooklyn
who like you a [ __ ]
right but that's right see i mean the
ladies at her workplace
the ladies that know her her one friends
that she went to school with
you best believe they in the dms talking
to each other like oh my god you know
what's immortal combat you know what she
said the other thing
you know it's dead
that's y'all now that i'm like women are
judgmental let me judge you
um i will give you a solid eight i think
that you're
very traditionally attractive and you
also seem very nice it's a very good
combination
thank you yeah i'll take it hello hello
i love your style thank you a lot can
you can you smile bigger
case ma you're not my time because
you know
you're really bringing up race a lot
without bringing it up
it's not race i was not talking about
that i was talking about
oh yeah you have a really nice smile
since you obviously like take care of
yourself
do you think that you do that more for
yourself do you think you do that to
have other people think of you as a
certain way
now it's much more for myself i used to
be like
pretty overweight and i used to wear
like very large like clothes to like
hide my
body and so now i show it off because i
worked for it you know
if you're showing it off so people
notice it
it's for others that's okay there's
nothing wrong with that
you make the transition you put in the
work live your best life
but if you hid your weight before and by
wearing baggy clothes
because you didn't want others to notice
and you lose that weight and now you're
wearing slim clothes
because you're so proud no it's for him
right it's for him you know what though
it's for him you know what though
to show it off it's really for him you
know what
it's okay it's not that deep i'll just
make it you seem very approachable like
if i saw you at the bar
i would come up to you you know to start
a conversation because
you seem very inviting i want to give
you a nine yeah i think i'm giving you a
nine
all right awesome hello hi i'm emily hi
emily i'm elena you are
gorgeous it seems like everyone who
looks
unemployable is rated highly vibrant
well you know that's what she said she's
i love the consistency with this girl
she's being consistent yeah i love
people that look like trash that's what
she said
i love losers that's what she said
consistent
yeah you know what it's like it's like
when you when you get yourself a
girlfriend
and then you're like on a tv interview
and someone asked like yeah so like what
are your standards you're like oh my
standards are super low and your
girlfriend's at home watching like
and all her girlfriends are also
watching that ooh i told you
but like gorgeous and cute at the same
time oh thank you you're
adorable you're the best
oh my gosh i like this i bet all of you
hate this because we're just giggling
back
yeah this is great footage
did you have braces yes for like a year
i had braces for
two years but they took them off myself
god damn girl
whoa you know how super glue they put on
that [ __ ]
god damn i had to do with nail clippers
i thought my teeth were straight enough
okay good job
so i think on my standards and society
standards i think would both probably
be a 10. oh you're just very you're
traditionally attractive but you're also
just very like
there's like confetti and fireworks in
my head right now like this is really
exciting stuff isn't that the harajuku
girl yeah
you see her giggling and everything and
stuff
that was her okay i practice i'm
practicing i see that
you know i always like looking at how
people write things it's interesting how
some people write
very objectively and other people rate
it from like how they personally view
um attractiveness from their lives
whether or not like me
what i would consider someone was
attractive to me most people would like
be like huh
but i'm also able to separate that with
what i think society generally
is attractive just based off of like how
many mates are going to get how many
people are going to be interested in you
etc etc so
if you're going to see that well yeah i
think it's got to be a funny thing to
to be married to someone who were like
i'll take anybody
it just happened to be you that's that's
a that's an interesting uh dynamic this
is the lucky number
yeah yeah cool it could have been anyone
really
[Laughter]
yeah you know uh josh was consistent she
was consistent
i like that i wonder how many wheelchair
jokes she's been hurt in her life
i feel like i feel like there's so many
you can i mean what wheelchair jokes
oh she heard them sure them all yeah she
heard them all yeah yeah i mean
yeah you know it's interesting when you
go to comedy shows and like um
people will show up like they they don't
want to be treated differently generally
no they don't i remember one time i was
doing a set at a comedy club and i was
doing this joke
and at some point involved somebody in
wheelchairs and everyone was laughing
and i looked in the corner there's a
grown up wheelchair just staring at me
and she was like this
what
because it was a brief pause because i
saw her with her mom and her mom's just
standing back like this
and then once i got the i was like i
mean
yeah and then i just went in bro i was
like wheelchairs you know what i mean
like if you're in a toxic relationship
you can't just walk away [ __ ] you gotta
roll away you know what i'm saying
you know i mean there's a whole bunch of
craig david songs you can't listen to
because they're not made for you you
know i was just having fun you wrote
yeah you wrote them yeah yeah yeah
which is fine that's what they yeah that
mo i'm not saying it's all
they want you have to have the perfect
setting but if you're roasting a bunch
of people you're like
yeah you blah blah blah blah blah yeah
you blah blah blah
blah yeah skip
you know they don't feel that yeah they
don't feel like because then it feels
like you're treating them like they're
not equal in that sense right or they
need to be
on the other hand you know you don't
think about it ever but like you imagine
living your life without legs and how
drastically different that would be
i just couldn't imagine it so when i
look at people in wheelchairs and
how they're able to handle that go
that's the cards they were dealt and
they managed with it so
this is some like i'm like ah they
worked it out
yeah there's like being in a wheelchair
and being [ __ ] those are like two
things i couldn't imagine
really if i know dick anymore like i'll
never have an erection again
that's crazy but you know it develops
where you're going to shoot yourself
you're going to delete yourself
oh well that's it for today's video tell
us what you think just follow subscribe
and share the video and you know i got a
patreon and everything and stuff so you
know
do all that stuff
[Music]
my
oh